[Music]
hello and welcome to atp report i'm
barry nussbaum we have a very wonderful
surprise guest for you well it's not a
real big surprise he's here regularly
but he's a member of the atp family but
first homework time please take out your
cell phone if you haven't signed up yet
and subscribe to our text message alert
system it will give you all of our shows
like this one on the palm of your hand
right in your cell phone absolutely free
all you have to do is text the word
truth in the message box and address it
to the number 88202
when you push send you'll be signed up
for free and you'll get all of our stuff
like the amazing
robert spencer who's here today as you
all know robert spencer is a regular
contributor to atp report he is the
founder of jihad watch he's published
and written over what 22 23 books he is
the scholar on islam in america and
around the world
welcome robert
good to talk to you barry as always
thank you
let's start off with what's going on
with the madness in ukraine um as
everybody knows there is an invasion
that has taken place
and
quite frankly it's very distressing
wondering whether or not we're going to
send american troops at some point but
you wrote an interesting article on g
hod watch that i want to ask you about
you talk about mark milley
our general who runs the armed services
for the president united states and he
has this idea in mind
that it's more important right now to
have a transgender policy that creates
the equality that general milley wants
and there's these bizarre training
programs on gender pronouns they're
coaching officers on
uh whether or not soldiers should
gender transition from one side of the
fence to the other
so while vladimir putin was amassing
hundreds of thousands of troops and
planes and tanks and mortars and cannons
we
were transgendering in the u.s army
um what do you make of this
it's madness barry and it shows why
putin very likely why putin thought that
it would be a good time to act not only
is biden obviously not the man in charge
not only is the administration obviously
weak but also its priorities are
ridiculous
it's not the job of the military to
coddle
the men who think they're women and
women who think they're men it's not the
job of the military to make sure that uh
transgender people feel comfortable it's
the job of the military to win wars and
defend the united states now when putin
saw that the military is instead
spending its time on this kind of
nonsense and critical race theory and
every other fashionable leftist item on
the agenda then it's clear that he
thought that the united states would not
pose a significant counterweight to his
plans uh we can only hope that biden
doesn't recklessly get this military
into a war at this point because it's
simply not ready for it it's been
paying attention to all the wrong things
and it would likely be an extraordinary
embarrassment for the country and
probably worse
well speaking of ukraine and the
president of the united states i have
got to get your comment on what our vice
president just said i'm going to read it
word for word so i don't get it wrong
here's the quote from
kamala harris ukraine is a country in
europe
it exists next to another country called
russia
russia is a bigger country russia is a
powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so basically
that's wrong
now this is not a quote from sesame
street from this week it's an actual
speech by the actual vice president of
what used to be the most powerful
country in the world you know
the united states and biden sends her to
meet with european leadership and she
comes up with statements like this does
anybody respect her on the world stage
oh i would doubt it i think that it's
another indication of the decline that
the united states is experiencing right
now that somebody like that is vice
president because we have to remember
barry this is not the only time she's
spoken in the in this sillier manner uh
remember not too long ago she was asked
about inflation and she said prices
are going up
and you know well i knew that already
but i was hoping for a little more
insight on the problem but she was not
of course going to offer it and
this shows people like putin and other
foreign leaders of malevolent intent
that the united states really isn't
anything to worry about the people at
the top are idiots and if they're not
idiots they're completely wrong-headed
they are paying attention as we were
just discussing in connection with
general milly to all the wrong things
well you know you're right yeah and and
sadly you're very right if i'm putin
right
and i'm reading this i don't know if i'm
looking at sesame street
or captain kangaroo for those of us that
are old enough to remember the captain
russia is a bigger country than ukraine
which is a smaller country and they're
both in europe
this person is one heartbeat away from
leading our country and makes statements
that sound like she belongs on well
educational tv for fourth graders it's
really pathetic so speaking about these
philosophies the creator
of the new york times controversial 1619
project is now commenting on well
surprise surprise russia and the ukraine
um
except this quote's really weird
nicole hannah jones as you remember um
created the 1619 project proving without
a shadow of a doubt that we are a white
racist misogynist white supremacist
country uh
intent on suppressing black people
forever
this was her quote a couple days ago
quote supremacy around the media
coverage of the war
in ukraine isn't even subtle and she
shared a clip of al jazeera you know the
arab cheerleading site citing the
prosperous middle class in the ukraine
who are desperately trying to board
trains to escape the war and then she
says what if i told you europe is not a
continent by definition by a
geopolitical fiction to separate it from
asia so the alarm about a european or
civilized or first world nation being
invaded is just a dog whistle in other
words
this war is because
there is no europe and it's just because
there's white people in the ukraine this
person is still lionized
by the new york times on a daily basis
it just shows the level of intellectual
discourse in america today everything
now has been politicized and the left
sees racism everywhere even when it's
not there uh
this is obviously a very tense situation
this could easily escalate into a
european war and into world war three
and so it's really
not to be downplayed and to act as if
people are only upset about it because
the ukrainians are white is just an
indication that somebody like uh what's
her name nicole hannah jones she can't
see
anything in the world except the racial
issue and so
uh she's constantly seeing it everywhere
well you know what they say to the man
who only has a uh hammer every two every
problem is a nail and this is an
indication of that an example
let me follow up on that
why is she still given a platform when
she says things that are so stupid that
we only care about the slaughter of the
ukrainians because they're white
and europe is not a continent it's
really part of asia and that's part of
white supremacy i mean come on robert
people are publishing this drivel on a
daily basis
they only have hammers too barry they uh
see everything in terms of racism i
think their agenda is to stir up racial
strife in the united states i think
that's what the 1619 project is all
about the whole idea is to
not to allay or alleviate
racial strife and resentment but to
increase it and that's the whole agenda
here in order ultimately to engulf the
nation in a civil war so that there will
have to be an authoritarian crackdown
and the end of constitutional rule
followed by some kind of dictatorship uh
obviously a leftist woke dictatorship
as david horowitz is so memorably said
inside every leftist is a totalitarian
screaming to get out and so all the
members of the intelligentsia that echo
what nicole hannah jones says it's
because they have the same agenda
scary stuff
speaking of which you wrote an article
about my hometown that really has me
upset
not the article itself but what you
reported from san diego a girl scout
troop which i always admired the girl
scouts i mean it's a service
organization they teach wonderful skills
they are now learning in san diego how
women in islam
are equal to men in islam
and
yet as you point out
the quran teaches that men are superior
to women and they should beat them if
they just might fear disobedience men
have authority over women because allah
made them that way and they spend their
wealth to maintain their women good
women are obedient they guard the unseen
parts because allah has guarded them so
on and on and on of all the reasons why
you beat your women and you control your
women and you sell your women and you
can kill your women and the girl scouts
in san diego are teaching women are
equal to men come on robert who creates
this insanity and why is it tolerated
well this is a largely somali muslim
migrant girl scout troop
and so
uh the local paper in san diego i guess
it's the union tribune they were
teaching this they were showing
reporting about this showing how
wonderful it was that the girl scouts
were giving these muslim students these
muslim girls the opportunity to learn
more about their religion the problem is
is that these are girls they're going to
grow up and they're going to come up
against almost certainly
the hard edge of reality
and that is that they're going to
realize
no doubt unpleasantly that islam doesn't
really teach
what they've been saying but these
things are constantly spread
particularly in the united states but
also in western europe primarily in
order to
fool
non-believers and make them complacent
about the nature of islam and the nature
of sharia islamic law but there's a
human cost to this and this story
illustrates that
well thanks for bringing it to my
attention even though i'm embarrassed
for san diego and shame on the union
tribune i used to deliver that paper
many years ago
and they report this like it's great
news hey look at the equality even
though as you point out and you've been
writing about it in dozens of books it's
a complete lie
and yet it's reported as a fact
and when there's not a robert spencer
out there to correct it with chapter and
verse
people just go oh isn't that lovely
they're like us
robert where can people find out about
you
um at ghodwatch.org online the only site
in the world that uh gives you news
about jihad activity which is still very
much with us in the united states and
around the world jihad watch rs on
twitter and there's even a jihad watch
facebook group
and all of you out there in atp land
please follow robert if you want to know
anything about this profoundly
urgent subject he is the source and he
will teach you not only
what the truth is but he'll give you the
source to go look it up for yourself so
you
become
someone that can defend their position i
strongly urge it and for all of you that
joined us today on atp report with
robert spencer i appreciate you coming
on with us for atp report
i'm barry nussbaum